kind of look I've borrowed I borrowed
one of the functions we used over there
but I'm doing something to really
different here this time and this is the
second kind of situation or maybe third
lost count where you've got multiple
curves you need to divide things up okay
I need to consider two integrals the
area marked R is the one between the two
curves this is the area I'm interested
okay now in order to work out this area
there are two integrals in my head that
I can use to calculate this right
firstly if I integrate over this
interval by the way I don't know what
the interval is yet but we'll find out
shopping if I integrate over this
interval and this is my integrator okay
what area will I go and get this area
realize I'll get a well I'm gonna get
all these straight edges you find if I'm
here in here right you can see you can
see I'm going to get a trapeze you do
you see that yeah on so trapeziums
yeah they actually talk a lot when
you're debating because every time you
do get a straight line that doesn't have
its the horizontal we get a trapezium
which is important for us later now if I
integrate this from there to there I'll
get that hold your peace I don't want
the whole trapezium so what do I need to
subtract okay now in order to get the
green one right what I've got to do is
take the trapezium and subtract these
bits here see that if I take the
trapezium and subtract the blue area
then I'm gonna get the green area okay
so that's just an idea by subtraction
now the area that I've just shaded in
blue what is that area it's the area
beneath the parabola do you see that so
in the same boundaries again from A to B
to get the blue area I just need to
integrate this guy
okay from whatever that is its whatever
it is okay now think about that thinking
about what we just said
right the area I want the area is the
integral of this one right the integral
from I'm just going to call a and B for
I don't know what there's not allowed it
to be of X right that would give me the
trapezium and then I need to subtract
the other area right which is again from
A to B of what is it X minus 2 squared
DX
okay I'm going to pause there for a
moment this is two integrals it's two
integrals okay I can do these two
integrals I can do them separately
there's no problem with that I'll get
the right answer as we just argue okay
but there's a quicker way to do this
right
do you recall do you recall when we
talked about the properties of definite
integrals
we talked about ways to divide up
integrals right like you could have an
integral that was made up of different
parts and you could separate them out
here is an example right I told you and
you've got to see your book so you don't
need to rewrite it you've got this
here's one integral and it can slice it
up I can say take that integrand in that
injury and I just treat them separately
right he's 1 and here is the other okay
now even though it's not immediately
obvious because it's actually something
sort of stopping you right do you see
there's a distinct similary this
property of definite integrals and what
I wrote over there like this is just a
special version of this line do you see
it right addition it's subtraction
really the same kind of operation just
in Reverse right so for instance if I
change this sum of integrals to a
difference between two integrals and
that'll change this guy here also to a
difference D agree with that so the
difference between two integrals is the
integral of the difference right which
is exactly the same as differentiating
right if you differentiate one thing
take away another right you might as
well differentiate each of them
separately and that means you can go
backwards and forwards between those
okay so therefore up here right rather
than deal with them as two separate
things
I'm going to evaluate one integral right
there's this guy up the front right now
why is he up the front why haven't I got
them switched around
yeah very good so I'm actually going to
say before I say that like actually the
reason why is because this trapezium is
the bigger area I am subtracting a
smaller area but another way of
geometrically saying is that the reason
why it's bigger is because that X lying
everywhere in this interval the straight
line is above the parabola do you see
that so that's why it ends up being a
bigger area so I'll go X take away and
the parabola is beneath it so now the
reason why it's advantageous to us is
because when I expand X minus 2 or
squared I'm going to get some like terms
so these guys will simplify the with
each other and then I'll have to
integrate less things in summary
interpret okay
so just before we leave that what I'm
talking is this which is also just a
cube that's the top function and then
because we use blue for that area
underneath the second integral the one
you're subtracting is the one function
now what would happen just out of
curiosity what would happen if I switch
them around by accident like what if I
accidentally got the order incorrect I
all happen is a changes so I don't get a
negative area okay so that's a signal to
me that I've done something wrong now
you shouldn't just accidentally get a
negative and then just slap my minus
sign in front at the front if you go
back and you should make sure you get
the order right because which one's
above and which ones below kind of
matters right it's like we should use
subtractive do we
okay so the last thing I need before I
can actually do this definite integrals
I need some boundaries so can we find
the boundaries
what do I do yeah I need to find these
points of intersection
and this is commonly the first step
right I need to know where they
intersect I just need the x-values
because that will give me a lower and an
upper bound
okay so let's quickly solve that x
equals X minus 2 all squared this is to
find the points of intersection I
already know what this is so I'm going
to solve for x squared minus 5x plus 4
equals 0 what's the factorization nice
easy numbers for you 1 & 4 okay so
there's my 8 and this might be now I'm
ready to evaluate this integral okay so
this is nice because having dealt with 2
I can combine them into one so I can
just say area I don't need to say a 1 or
into readable the area is from 1 to 4
I'm gonna put in my top integrated first
my top function and then I'm going to
subtract my body functions so I might as
well expand cuz I'm gonna have to
collect some light tones in a second
okay like so and I'm going from 1 to 4
oh okay what do we get 2 minus x squared
X plus 4 X so this is plus 5x and then
I've got playing secure this I said can
we factorize this x squared minus 5x
plus 4 this is this actually okay I
could factor Isis but there's no point
in fact right here right because they
have a product that's hard to integrate
I don't do that expanding is the easiest
form so I will just leave it like that
and then I just think it will the
premium for each one so this is going to
be X cubed over 3 - excuse me
you evaluated him from one to four okay
all right let's do the top of one four
and a half sounds like what I got before